Restaurants are overrated.
That's the problem,
you know,
it's like every restaurant that's,
that's gotten great.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
a recommendation tends to combat it
with,
with a lot of exaggeration that I don't
know if that,
is that my fault is that,
you know,
is that the public,
is that the eating public's fault or is
it the media's fault?
I'm not really sure.
But uh,
yeah,
something going on there where the
expectation level is just too high and
it's always going to disappoint,
which is why you know,
you're here nine times out of 10,
you here,
I just like going to like the informal
place,
you know,
down the street,
the place that a Mexican burrito and
stuff,
of course you do because your
expectation level is nothing and it's
tasty food and it meets the expectation
and it's cheap.
So you know,
and it's fun and informal and like,
you know,
it informs you and,
and,
and sustains you in a way that,
you know,
a big fancy restaurant can't.
So I don't know,
I find myself being disappointed going
out so often,
but I,
I don't know if that's me just expecting
a lot and then falling short or if it's
being played up before
I get there.